Your attention, for example, is handled by unconscious forces - and you know it, you know it perfectly
This is another important observation. As you know, if you sit out of
Study time
For example, your conscious attention is to be studied.
But you know well that all kinds of illusions that distract your attention will enter your imagination
Non-stop, annoying, and there's not much you can do about it, maybe, wait
As you know, so you will be sitting there and your attention will go away. You will think
I do not know
You might want to watch Gene Virgin (a US series) on Netflix or something like that, or maybe it's time to get a peanut butter sandwich
Or you must take out the bunched rabbits from under the bed
Or maybe you take a grain of sugar or maybe a cup of coffee
Or it is like all the systems in you that want to have nothing
Very happy just in order to sit there while reading this thing that you are bored of and so float on the roof and try to
Controlling your perceptions and your actions non-stop, you probably think this is stupid
In any case, why should I read this damned article, what do I do at university and what is the point of life?
You can really do well
You can go if you try to avoid doing your homework
And then you may think. Well what are you trying to avoid it
After I took the damn course, I told myself to sit down. Why do not you listen?
Well, because you're in a mess, that's why you do not get control of yourself at all
And no more control over this laptop
Well, then there is the memory function of the subconscious mind
There are job solutions and these are interesting. The subconscious mind contains once voluntary habits now
The trusting and separate elements of the personality, which may lead to an intrusive existence. this is interesting
I would like to root that out more into procedural memory
You also know that what you have done is practicing certain habits
Whatever they can be let them be called bad habits, and you like to control those things
But you can not when you talk for example
You use a word for example "and" as you know "and you say" Ummmm "a lot and you do so to be good at it
And you want to stop, but you do not print because you built this small machine in being right
It's nervous and not under conscious control and anything you exercise
Becomes it; becomes part of you, this is another element of the subconscious. Different part, and then there is an innovative part
What's this ... okay? You know you're sitting and maybe trying to write something or maybe you want to
Produce a piece of art, or something musical, or maybe you're dreaming in bed
And you have all these strange ideas, especially in dreams. It's like ... what? Where do these things come from and what's more strange
One of the really weird things about dreams and almost strange is that you are an observer in your dream
It's like a dream is something that happens to you. Well, you're dreaming, theoretically, how can you be an observer?
It's almost like you're watching a video game or a movie